tiens est-ce qu'on peut parler de euh
Mathieu Perry Matthieu Perry oui bah oui
bah c'est c'est non mais écoute
excuse-moi de te faire chier hein euh on
a des révélations de son ex-ptit ami la
drogue pourrait avoir finalement causé
sa mort alors oui c'est une longue
interview qui a donné son ancienne
petite amie Cathy éedouard qui avec qui
il est sorti en 2006 et qui a été son
assistante en 2011 et donc elle fait des
révélations assez exceptionnelles alors
comme comme on le sait le 28 octobre
dernier la star de Friends est morte
elle a été retrouvée inanimée dans son
jacuzzi et alors du coup il y a eu des
autopsies qui ont été faites enfin des
analyses sanguines qui ont pas mené à
grand-chose ce qu'on a vu c'est qu'il y
avait pas de drogue type métamphétamine
ou ou cocaïne méamphétamine ouais
métamphétamine non c'est pas ça ah bon
pardon spécialiste Dr
c'est donc voilà et du coup là sa
nouvelle pe enfin son exptite amie nous
a apporte un regard différent sur ça
parce que elle a pour elle il y avait
des éléments précurseurs qui montrai au
contraire qu'il avait rechuté rechutter
voilà donc voulez que je vous donne ces
éléments alors déjà pour commencer vous
voulez bosser ou pas elle pose des
question question donc déjà ce ce qui
est marrant c'est que elle raconte que
elle a donc elle a rencontré Matth Perry
grâce à son grand-père qui se
connaissait et ensuite 6 mois plus tard
elle l'a revu aux alcooliques anonymes
et que quand elle bossait avec lui
c'était là au moment où il était le plus
drogué que il était au SOMUM de son
addiction et elle raconte même que il
l'envoyait chercher du crack alors que
elle était enceinte donc voilà et elle
ce qu'elle explique dans l'interview
c'est qu'il y a plein d'éléments qui
montrent effectivement qu'il était
toujours addicte accro à la drogue
contrairement à ce que certains on dit
parce que déjà pas l'impression d'être
un peu
seul
moi j'adore es très professionnel ma ch
mais je sais plus ce qu'elle a dit non
mais non mais elle a raison il y a plein
d'éléments elle dit que sa prise de
drogue a toujours été liée à l'eau moi
j'étais déjà au resto en train de
commander un
tyram vér non mais non mais elle dit que
c'est un hasard s'il soit retrouvé
d'enfant jacuzzi quand il était dans le
jacuzzi quand il prenait des bains c'est
quand il prenait de la drogue donc elle
dit je suis sûr qu'il a récidivé avec ce
mode opératoire elle dit aussi que quand
il se faisait appel matman voilà matman
à un moment un moment il dit je suis
redevenu matman en quelque sorte
matman mat de son prénom man parce qu'il
était fan de Batman voilà et et ce
matman il l'utilisait à l'époque quand
elle était avec elle au moment où il
prenait de la drogue donc effectivement
il y a un environnementiss prends pas
pour Michel Mar
mais il y a tout un environnement qui
fait penser à cet exptit ami de 2006
qu'il était peut-être retombé dans la
drogue VO voà et comment il faisait pour
être aux alcooliques anonymes alors
qu'il est super connu
c'était cétait
en y a plein
d'cteur il y a pas mal de gens qui
peuvent plus
blir préfère te dire je préfère te le
dire je préfère te dire des choses non
mais c'est vrai et donc donc là non mais
c'est vrai que vous avez vu ce qu'elle a
dit he
ça elle a dit selon elle Matthew avait
céd à ces vieux démons avant de mourir
je connais matthw il ne se serait jamais
noyé comme ça je pense qu'il reprenait
des cachés la semaine avant ce qui est
arrivé c'est ce qu'a dit Katy
Edward il a aucun il a aucun lien de
parenté avec Katy non aucun Katy P fen
non ils ont dit qu'aucun caché ce
qu'elle a dit ils ont dit qu'aucun caché
sous ordonnance n'a été retrouvé sur
place ce qui me surprend pas parce qu'il
n'avait pas pour habitude de laisser de
la drogue traîner il était paranoïque et
prenait tout pour qu'il n'y ait aucune
preuve et sortait en reprendre quand il
en avait envie c'est donc elle dit et
voilà elle revient sur matman ce truc
avec matman n'était pas une chose à
laquelle il faisait référence quand
quand il était sobre matman sortait
quand il n'était pas sobre et qu'il se
sentait invincible oui puis elle dit
aussi que ça aussi c'était assez force
qu'elle qu' prenait jusqu'à 55 cachés de
viicondine c'est analgésique c'est un
analgésique qu hein c'est un antidouleur
et qu'il en prenait jusqu'à 55 par jour
donc c'est c'est énorme oh ah
ouais donc c'est ouf la seule chose
c'est que donc c'est un témoignage de
quelqu'un qui l'a connu il y a bien
longtemps donné à un journal anglais
appelle the Sun qui est parfois réputé
pour acheter des témoignages c'est pas
vrai le c'est non le Sun c'est pres PL
fiable tableï anglais qui qui parfois
piège des joueurs de foot en
voilà mais c'est c'est parfois un
journal qui a dépasser les bandes de la
déontologie faut le dire quand mêmeam
parce que la déontologie le droit
anglais n pas du tout le même qu'en
France donc ils peuvent se permettre
plus de choses que que la press people
en France non d'une manière générale
c'est le son a plutôt des infos
qu'est-ce qu'il a lui non j'ai d Sun
c'est l'inverse de Moon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Moad franchement G on va parler de
Neymar ouais Neymar Neymar alors Neymar
c'est assez incroyable qu'est-ce qu'il a
comme rasera
allez vous avez vu un PUL un P une r
avec elle après avoir trompé sa sa femme
enfin la mère de son enfant 92 fois on
apprend qu'en fait he pardon pardon ah
on apprend qu'il a qu'il a en fait
employé une une une femme de ménage de
façon illégale qu' l'a que qu'il attaque
d'ailleurs au prude homme alors cette
cette jeune femme est une brésilienne de
37 ans qui l'a fait bosser
de 2021 à 2022 enfin pratiquement 7
jours sur enfin 7 jours sur 7 avec des
horaires énormes qui dépassent même les
les amplitudes réglementaires puisqu'il
a il a faisait bosser 60 heur par
semaine alors qu'elle aurait dû en
bosser que 40 il a
rémunéré selon la plainte en liquide il
lui demandait de faire le ménage elle
devait aussi faire les ongles de sa
petite ami enfin
bref bah c'est ce qu'il lui demandait
elle était aussi elle
é oui dire elle éétait les avocats
parlent même de de
d'esclavagisme moderne et que du coup
aujourd'hui elle lui réclame
368000 € au Prudhomme il l'a jeté dehors
quand elle était enceinte
pratiquementché elle se tordait de
douleur et il c'est pour ça qu'elle a
fait c'est d'ailleurs ou pour ça que
elle a porté plainte parce qu'en fait
quand elle est elle a dû travailler
quasiment jusqu'au bout de sa grossesse
et puis quand elle a accouché elle
pensait retrouver son travail et là plus
personne ne lui répondait au téléphone
donc bah là elle s'est dit je vais
prendre contact avec des associations
parce qu'il faut quand même savoir que
cette cette femme qui a quatre enfants
aujourd'hui se retrouve quand même au
Secours populaire pardon populaire
populaire on a des nouvelles de Stéphane
Plazza également oui Stéphane Plazza
alors alors quelle est sa racera alors
alors Stéphane Plazza c'est la c'est la
Une de publi alors qui a-t-il Stéphane
Plazza c'est la Une de public cette
semaine qui nous explique que Stéphan
plazard en fait ne serait pas parti se
cacher ne serait pas parti au Canada
pour des raisons professionnelles et
qu'en fait il vivrait caché en région
entre Paris et la région parisienne
entre trois maisons qu'il aurait où il
en fait il serait oblig il est dans
l'immobilier lui il pas il est pas il
est pas emmerdé lui hein non mais ça
c'est comme si tu disais un primeur n'a
pas de fruit et donc il se voilà il se
cacherait il se déguiserait même pour
sortir et que du coup tout les tous les
toutes les photos qu'il met sur
Instagram c'est du fake parce que en
fait il est planqué chez lui ok bon
alors c'est pas totalement vrai ah
d'accord c'est pas fini d'accord ah
pardon oui donc non c'est pas totalement
vrai parce que effectivement Stéphane
Plaz est revenu il y a une dizaine de
jours de tournage de
de recherche à part et maisons et il
était bien au Canada pour faire faire ce
tournage très bien merci en tout cas
point de vue il y avait Florent panier
hier on va reparler lundi hein